welcome to this video playing KSS para
casa espero something from spain
relatively low rated view you don't get
them players of that rating range so
often but that's a good thing throughout
the auto pairing and some also players
that are slightly lower rated getting
the chance to get better on position
very often in this challenge based
formats when you try to challenge a
better player he simply refuses to play
and you never get the chance to play a
really oh yeah much stronger opponent 97
yeah guess I'll take
just seems that it tries to to sacrifice
but there came a fatigue but I can take
why not actually can take with the Queen
and I'll just play Bishop to e3 you can
play nite nite c5 but after just
coincident really see the point yeah one
that's interesting why would you want to
trade the Queen's here yeah ok I don't
mind a man-pon up again I can't cover
this takes on c3 on a to the poon rider
strapped so i'm just a pawn up for for
not much yeah but here the king where do
you put the King now preventing short
castles intending Bishop to c4 or b-five
and rookie won the some could easily get
very ugly very big attack yeah is very
tough to defend I think you shouldn't
have taken on c3 the bishop was a really
strong piece let's see rookie one coming
check okay so Knight d4 may be on 95
both quite good this some actually has
additional ideas maybe nine to be five
or push the f pawn and this is what I'm
doing now intending g4 def 5 and black
has a hard time to move yeah that's gone
g45 couldn't really defend that and f5
next he can take on c3 but then f five
wins the night you have the bishop on h6
is just a terrible terrible piece for
black
yeah I can just take it
black resigned yeah the disaster Adam it
really went went downhill with Queen B
form before that I'm not really
believing that black has sufficient play
but um it's it's it's certainly not lost
or anything you should just play some
normal moves Knight b6 for example or
castles and say something oops are not
285 so let's say here and just castles
and this is a good very good diagonal
went um it's not so clear why this
really am a pool the full pawn the head
or if black has some comp maybe he has
at least a bit queen is still vulnerable
maybe I should still casts a long just
get out of this and get the rook into
play I don't really fear this kind of
move I have a very strong bishop after
that yeah well in the game I think black
is basically lost as too much if it does
not take which is not a nice move to
play and I have did this kind of ideas
here here it's just it's just bad the
way it went down again so it's basically
lost no way to defend that alright
thanks for watching